the jurogan experience
i don't know i don't know either i like
vaccines you know yeah i'm excited
um i like vaccines i i
mean um the
problem that a lot of people have is
that this was fast-tracked
and they get nervous about they do they
do
possible potential side effects and we
don't know what those are going to be
and then there's a lot of people that
are very uncomfortable with the idea of
getting very sick
after they take the vaccine which seems
to happen with 80 percent of the people
that take it
and so they're concerned about that 80
of people who are taking this vaccine
yes that's not what i heard well that's
what bill gates has said
bill gates yeah i don't know i mean i
don't know if we see it i don't know if
we can look it up
and play it for you pull it off of i
know it's weird when people say that
people like wait what
um it's on my instagram there's a
interview with bill gates where he's
talking about i believe this is the
moderna
vaccine the pfizer vaccine has a very
similar effect
because it's um the way this uh mrna
vaccine
works they've taken the common cold
vaccine and added this
to it your body develops these proteins
to fight off but you get sick
yeah i mean well i i can't say i don't
know you know i mean i've read the sort
of report the readout from
pfizer and mederna biontech and they
said there were very few
serious side effects i mean i don't know
i don't know serious or not i mean i got
the flu shot
you know uh whenever it was a couple
months ago and
you know my arm hurt for a couple days
i wouldn't do it just that's just the
injections yeah your body didn't feel
bad right but it was fine
you know i felt okay this is different
than that um this is different than that
and there's a
there's a consequence of taking this and
i'm not saying that i won't take it i
will
it's if it's safe i will encourage other
people to take it too
but there's a reality of taking this
particular
vaccine that it's going to make a lot of
people feel like [ __ ]
and it'll last a couple days and look
you can play
play that video oh
okay but it's in the the it's in the uh
feed
it's in the igtv but if you just go to
my instagram feed from the last time
uh the the dylan jones episode
um it's uh it's that's just what it is
hold on keep going
wait a minute did they remove it
oh my god did they remove it from my
instagram
is that real holy [ __ ] dude
that is crazy hold on let me check
because that's kind of crazy if they
removed it from my instagram that's kind
of crazy because this was a
i believe it was an nbc interview
oh they removed it wow
okay well here here i got i got an
article from from science it says
uh there's fever and aches that are
intense in some cases
but not dangerous you found it okay okay
it hasn't been removed then
okay here we go has it been removed why
don't i find it i've
i don't know it's a month ago says
october 28th right
okay play it this video was edited
though remember
also no no no
no no no no that's a totally different
video that's a totally
different video that video was the video
where people were talking about
uh that bill gates is concerned with the
uh profit margin
from vaccines but that is we should talk
about that too because that's actually
important
that's actually important because that's
really distorted and that's not what he
was saying at all
he was not talking about profit
concerning we looked after the second
dose
at least 80 percent of participants
experienced a systemic
side effect ranging from severe chills
to fevers
so are these vaccines safe
well the the fda
not being pressured will look hard at
that the fda is the gold standard of
regulators
uh and their current guidance on this
if they stick with that is is very very
appropriate
uh and you know they it
the the the side effects were not super
severe that is it didn't
cause permanent health problems for uh
the things that they you know moderna
did have to go with a fairly
high dose and so uh you know to get the
antibodies some of the other vaccines uh
are going able to go with lower doses to
get
uh responses that are are pretty high
including
the jnj and the pfizer and so there's a
lot of
characteristics of these vaccines um
it's great that we have multiple of them
uh
that are going out there and yes you
know the data better than i do
but the bill though the data showed that
everybody with a high dose had
a side effect yeah but
some of that is is not dramatic where
you know it's just
you know super painful but yes there we
need to make sure there's not severe
side effects the fda
i i think will do a good job of that
despite the pressure how many doses of
the vaccine will we need
well none of the vaccines at this point
appear like they'll work with a single
dose that was the
the hope at the very beginning uh
maybe one of them particularly in the
second generation won't surprise us we
hope just two
although in the elderly sometimes uh
it it takes more and and so making sure
we have lots of elderly people
in the trial will give us that data no
so let's be clear
okay so it is hold on a second yeah if
that is all it is it's just you you have
severe
chills and you feel like [ __ ] for a
couple days that is way better than
getting the coronavirus
and risking the potential death and side
effects and
you know the long-haul people
experiencing blood clots and if it's
better than that yeah but it's just
it's not a free ride so i just i just
want to get the numbers what i see here
from from science is that
uh the the sort of fatigue you know that
you were talking about
feel like [ __ ] for two days they did
about ten percent of people
had had the side effects which hold on a
second but why is bill gates saying 80
well no she was saying it's some side
effect
comes in 80 percent right but like what
you were talking about
is in a subset you know of the people
get it well
i didn't know i don't know if that's
true because there's many articles
about the the side effects of this
vaccine i've never seen one of them
that relegated it to 10 of the
population that took the
well actually i mean specifically the
second dose
yeah the other thing about this is you
have to take two the second dose seems
to be the doozy for people
right i mean i guess that's that's the
tough one um
now do you think so this is something
that's interesting is i have like one
set of conversations with people
and they're saying who's gonna be able
to get the vaccine like how are we going
to roll this out
you know healthcare workers essential
workers all this other kind of stuff and
then there's another conversation where
people are like
maybe you're not going to want to get it
right and me i'm like
i'm really eager you know give it to me
tomorrow i don't even care that the fda
is not done
why is that um you're not worried about
side effects hey i'm not worried about
side effects why are you not worried
about side effects
you guys fever for a couple days i mean
that's what if that's all we know of now
yeah but look long-haul coveted
survivors one of the things they're
finding is these people have blood clots
like many many months later no i mean i
know like a serious
serious but that's it like i i would
really like to not get
coveted yeah sure so what if there's a
similar
situation with the vaccine what if the
vaccine
this is not outside the realm of
possibility that the vaccine gives some
sort of a
a side effect that that's unintended i
mean i have a lot of confidence
in the basic process here with the
vaccine but this isn't the basic process
this is a completely new process
much faster than any process i mean it's
an unusually rapid
development i mean it's an usually rapid
development because they have this m
r m rna i don't know what that means
i mean it's messenger rna but i don't
know what it means
um so it just means that it's tricky
it's not giving you a
like a dormant version right so there's
no there's no virus right there's a
particle that's
specially designed it triggers
antibodies yeah we create them
and so i think the basic antibody immune
response
situation is fairly well understood
scientifically
it's why we're pretty confident that the
people who've recovered you know are
immune that
you know younger and healthier people in
most cases
are okay if they get sick they get
better um
so to me like it's a good thing i'm all
for it
i'll take it i'll get the fever but i'm
also not
i want to walk the line like i want to
encourage people to take vaccines
like as a responsible person but also
knowing that the supplies will be short
if somebody doesn't want it like
somebody else
will take that dose but you know what
one of the best things uh
in terms of uh outcomes is
vitamin d like vitamin d deficiencies
are a huge part of
negative covid outcomes and then uh one
in one
some people some studies about that yeah
in one study 84
of the people that were in the icu had
deficient levels of vitamin c and only
four percent
had sufficient levels of vitamin d
vitamin d is a huge problem
and it's not just a vitamin it's a
hormone you know one when j
mackey was on the other day he was
trying to say that it's a precursor to
hormones so i had to look it up that's
not true
it's a hormone vitamin d is actually a
hormone and it's weird because we call
it a vitamin but it regulates so many
things in the body and it has a
significant impact on the immune system
but you never hear anybody telling you
to supplement with vitamin d
you're not seeing this from any of the
leaders any of these politicians that
are shutting things down
even fauci has said it recently that
vitamin d
does seem to have a pretty significant
impact but health experts like people
that
study like the mechanisms of disease and
vitamin
supplementation like particularly dr
rhonda patrick had a thing on
her twitter when she published a study
that showed positive outcomes and kovid
vitamin d is a huge factor catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience